he's a scottish-born chef and
restaurateur his restaurants have been
awarded 16 Michelin stars and currently
hold 14 he's known for creating TV
programs about competitive cookery and
food
he's Gordon Ramsay and here his top ten
rules for success my advice to young
Chefs from the age of 16 to sort of 2930
is 14 years of a sponge you're absorbing
knowledge don't take a job for take up
money don't worry about earning 500
pound a month or a year more somewhere
else
go and get knowledge because that
becomes a bigger passport for everything
the money will come once you've mastered
your craft and you become incredibly
talented work for big chefs and find a
difference level of conflict when things
get too comfortable and you're still
living with your parents and you've
still got your first job and you want to
move out because everything's to come
blur get out put yourself in a strange
situation in the middle of Barcelona put
yourself in the middle of Paris put
yourself in the middle of Belgium and
see what's available it's amazing how
much confidence it gives you more
importantly it's great to eat and travel
at the same time fantastic there's one
thing I've learnt and experience is that
you know if you don't open up and you
don't delegate then you'll kill yourself
and if there's one thing that I've
managed to understand is the art of
delegation because if I can pass on you
know to Claire Smith to areum my palette
my understanding my knowledge then grab
it run it and then pass on to your team
don't hold that inside key to a
successful business is remembering the
customers King because without them WA
nobody and so i from a chef's point of
view all for myself in a customer's
situation where I sit from their eyes I
don't cook for chefs
every time chefs come into the dining
room Thursday news turn up the place
upside down start photographing the food
and and they're constantly you know
dissecting the food as a time as opposed
to enjoying it so I always look at from
a customer's perspective because their
king and without them we're history that
takes years to become a great chef what
you need to do is establish confidence
in yourself cooking is an amazing
journey and don't that you can learn it
within three or four years it's like
studying medicine it's over a ten to
fifteen year period I'm 42 years of age
I'm still learning new exciting things
now that I bring back to the fold but
more importantly vision I didn't think
French was important at school and I
kicked myself now because I went live in
France for three years and became
bilingual but I wish I'd studied harder
with a second language on my belt that
gives you a different culture gives you
a completely different level of
confidence learning French French
cuisine mannerism and cooking in a very
robust tenacious way so yeah vision and
open-mindedness and we never cut corners
and then you start cutting corners and
food timeout
there's no worse job to have than to cut
corners in food so attention detail
amazing exciting journey one of the very
few jobs anywhere in the world that you
can travel get paid and experience
phenomenal food anywhere in the world
brilliant I'm going to teaching the
common-sense rules to ensure
front-of-house runs smoothly starting
with the basics on the menu tonight I
think everything should should be quite
sending out if you in official meat is
your favorite but everything tonight is
absolutely fresh stop yep yeah okay
right what you need to do is in relax a
great service is attentive without being
noticed so far you're making much pitch
and hasn't come out yet
that's how we were tating you are right
ladies sit down with Donna night at the
table take an order of four okay right
off we go here we go
good evening everyone
and for you order tonight what would you
like beetroot starter and the halibut
for Maine please the beetroot and the
halibut white camellias I'm really that
pained enough yes it was painful here's
the thing sit down yeah where's the
patty look at that I swear to God is
writing of a six year old it's all about
engaging in the customers to start off
with done it was like to start
Manorville prawns ever Michael's
certainly so P and C and Madame mackerel
halibut certainly of course lovely and
it's just the p.m. MCC is a goddamn
revelation back relax you don't have to
have everything in detail here you'll be
surprised three tables land the line 30
tables down the line if you continue to
work at it you start to become
incredibly charming you know why because
your confidence levels are there stay in
front of a competition because there's
two ways in this industry you you move
with it or it moves you and I've seen so
many sad stories across the decade where
chefs have just got lazy got lazy given
up and lost that hunger to be
competitive because it's the best job in
the world that's not really a job it's a
passion because when you're rubbing
shoulders and here we are now 10 years
later and I've got a restaurant next
door to Jamie Oliver's and we're both
literally 2 meters apart phenomenal chef
and we keep each other on our toes so
that's exciting for me and that's been
the one key issue across the 10 years of
filming Kitchen Nightmares never ever
ever give up my first passion before
food was was football but as always a
good eater great level of food and grew
up partly in Scotland polygon south so
we had that sort of token of
appreciation of home-cooked food then I
was very lucky to get on a foundation
course spending the last year in my
school at a foundation course
maths English to nap days a week and
then learning to cook for to nap days a
week and it was a sort of new experiment
now we had trouble with buy my first set
of whites and chef knives and we
depended on the bamboo round table to
come up with something like 85 90 pounds
the mum dad didn't have to get my first
set of whites so I still remember that
day now and how I ecstatic and happy I
was when I got given my first set of
whites my knives and all of a sudden I
want to go on that mission football was
a sort of huge burning ambition and I
was trying to decide yeah I had a
horrific injury where I smashed my
cartilage and and then all of a sudden
you know would you do he said they can
get better but I had this little burning
desire of this sort of chef this this
ambition and then I sort of channeled
that frustration from football into
cooking in a way that I I just I just
wanted to learn the foundation course
was huge they're sitting gild 706 and I
was a mature part-time student and mum
didn't have the money to send me to
college full-time so it was it was hard
but what I did do is take a job in the
industry I work six days a week and went
to college one day week so then
everything started becoming clearer got
my qualifications the basic and then
went to London and that's where it
really just you know took off this is my
little nice pass but a specialised nice
was and it's the kind of thing that I
picked myself up after cycling - and
okay a beautiful piece of tuna to brush
that first little bit of mustard stops
it from drying out now sesame seeds just
beautifully roll that down I always
think about food or where I go so when
I'm training yeah I'm never very far
away from food at that extraordinary
moment at the start of Kona two years
ago where I was paddling at sort of half
past five of the morning waiting for
that amazing canna to go off to get rid
of the nerves I just started thinking
about recipes and dishes and how do I
get through this 3.8 K swim the garnish
very very simple and got potatoes I
start with a little teaspoon of olive
oil when the at least attained is nice
and crispy cut them in half put that
side down
so in my bowl there's the really nice
Sherlock rings olive nice wires black
olives some green beans and then in
there I'm just gonna open up some of
these little ancho is a little touch of
a [ __ ] Rhett this is class of
vinaigrette made with lots of lemon
juice and then look just mix that up
nicely with some fresh parsley your
tomatoes are sweet vinegar fresh lemon
juice in that lifts everything worked
1415 hours a day to perfect an absolute
stunning dish it disappears in two and a
half minutes and that's what I said it
loses you you you get on that journey
and nothing else matters except what you
put on the plate because you start off
with this raw ingredient and you go
through that journey sixty minutes later
you've got this this bit of magic also
it's an incredible passion it is a huge
canvas just take your cellophane
I want to use the little hearts just
open them up gently without sort of
ripping them get down to the heart and
cut the heart
into four chambers nice and crispy and
then from there as they start to cool
down she asked put a little touch of
vinaigrette over there
and hit them with your parsley food was
my calling I think because that was the
way I could sort of disappear disappear
travel learn and get really excited
about something and my first dream was
to go to France to understand why were
they the sort of foundation of cooking
why do they start it how do they start
it and I disappear I became French and
within 18 months I was fluent in the
language I was holding my own in a
foreign kitchen and I I was seriously
cook my ass off now the dressing very
very simple touch the vinaigrette and
then some fresh lemon juice
that gives a nice lightness vibrancy to
the dish as well which has lightly
dressed them my first head of knives was
bought by a charity and my parents can
afford to send me to cooking school and
this knife wallet was a swim bow is with
bright yellow handles and trust me I
couldn't cut butter but they looked the
part my mum had a tear in her eye
because she was upset she couldn't
afford it my first set of whites and my
first set of knives I've still got that
finally the tuna in the pan nice and hot
put a teaspoon of oil in there tuna into
the pan
90 seconds each five out initially
squeeze some fresh lemon juice on there
when you slice it let the knife do the
work fingers on top and just slice
through nice and carefully on three
knife slices food your a journey and
there's something quite amazing about
the way you cook of giving pleasure my
dream when I started out as a chef was
to discover every ingredient and never
be intimidated and not know what to do
with it to that level of perfection I
think I'm about 97% of the way there
there must be about 3 or 4 percent of
ingredients that I still haven't
discovered yet and that's the exciting
thing about food
is what I call I specialized Tuna
Nicoise and delicious when you get all
this knowledge and the advice for young
Chefs that are excited about opening
their own business don't shoot - hi
rations become successful because they
cook within the vicinity of their sat
within don't start reaching for Stars
and Stripes focus on your customers
they're your biggest critics secondly
keep it local become the best Bistro
then after the Bistro take it up a
little level but make sure your
customers new brigade go up with you
don't stand and shoot too high we'll
come back to buy yours I'm on a mission
to road-test some of the best celebrity
chef cookery courses on offer to you
first fanatic Aldo Zilly is my next
target the cheeky little bastard said
maybe one day I'd learn how to cook
properly well now he's got his chance to
teach me so I'm going undercover to road
test these cookery course to have a bit
of fun and to see what I can get away
with the sillies course costs 352 pounds
and on it you learn how to make stock
different types of pasta and how to
prepare and cook fish gonna come and set
up piercer
good night gentlemen gonna come up here
I can't wait to learn some these things
today to get on this course for
beginners I've told him on a novice but
will he notice that there's really an
award-winning chef in his kitchen time
for a bit of fun and the odd clue
there's no one of the with spots if you
don't want to mix too many colours into
the shot the minute colour vegetable the
stalks overheating so I take the matter
in hand
Willie twig see she's copy is a recon
song he's listening mr. silly I think
it's the earthiness I think it's really
okay but that the mother soars even if
it's ready he's impressed but oblivious
brilliant
next up Lily's shown us how he makes
pasta now it's our turn finally I want a
course where I get to make something so
this is when you've added too much flour
so quickly okay so it's really hard so
he thinks his crap does he time for a
second clue
well he spot that as mission start
pastor been made right under his nose
yeah look at this man look never make
Buster before that copper their lower
got fed to cheer we got around that I
blimey even after all that he hasn't
clicked
come on Aldo to housing and the course
moves on to sillies favorite fish we've
got to prepare our own place of fish for
cooking let's see what he makes of this
surely he'll smell something fishy when
I finish before most of the others have
even begun I've never done before this i
subjects call i that no i yes that move
thank you he's never done it before so
there's no truth al does miss the true
yet again or has he you know what you
remind me of Gordon Ramsay doesn't
remind you of Gordon Ramsay looks like
he's dead
are you sure he hasn't seen me bad ah
I'm about to get rumbled time to come
clean
mister with it a little bit of flour
wasn't it
Gordon Ramsay would season them good rum
who seasoned them I'll see I see is
enough to cut the cooking because I
don't like salt I can't eat too much
salt and good good Randy he's a
nightmare and so are you Dena Dena Jenai
I've known you since you were standing
there right I came today to learn
something and you've learned nothing
I've learned cause hang on hang on keep
it on you look much better thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Frank Robert jean-pierre asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know
which of Gordon Ramsay's top 10 rules
meant the most to you leave it in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon